[Musique]
on produit des noisettes en agriculture
biologique à la base mes parents ont
planté le verger en
2020 parce qu'ils sont gourmands et
ensuite je les ai rejoint en 2022 donc
il y a 2 ans pour justement toute la
partie transformation commercialisation
voilà valoriser notre production de
noisette parce que je suis encore plus
grandante que effectivement c'est une
histoire de famille on a fait la
première récolte en septembre 2022 et là
on entame notre deuxème récolte et cette
année on prévoit on espère doubler la
quantité
récoltée on espère récolter une
quarantaine de tonnes à maturité c'est
fait pour les gangs
d'écureil en France les producteurs de
noisettes alors il y en a beaucoup dans
le Sud-Ouest mais à les transformer on
peut se compter sur les doigts d'une
main et en agriculture biologique on est
les seuls à aller jusqu'au bout de la
transformation
alors on a trois variétés de noisettes
différentes on a la Butler qui est une
Américaine la merveille de bolviller qui
est une allemande et la Tonda d' typhony
qui est une italienne donc c'est trois
variétés avec des grosses noisettes ce
qui permet de les travailler entières
après et des noisettes très savoureuses
très goûtu d'accord alors on a deux
gammes de produits on a la gamme de
sachet avec des noisettes entières
toréfiées ce qui est parfait pour
l'apéritif on a du granul et de la
poudre de noisette pour les amateurs de
pâtisserie et là on vient de sortir
trois nouveaux produits de l'huile de
noisette de la pâte à tartiné et de la
crème de noisette avec que deux
ingrédients 65 % de noisette et du sucre
de canne pour la crème de noisette on
est 100 % bio tous nos ingrédients sont
bio du sucre au cacao au plus proche du
verger vous pouvez nous retrouver chez
les café trofrast qui est une épicerie
au centre-ville de Loudin dans les
magasins de producteur et les épiceries
fines aux alentours donc Azel rideau
Chinon tour Poitier on est à la biocope
on vend aussi nos noisettes aux
restaurateurs pâtissiers chocolatiers on
travaille notamment avec le restaurant
au local à Chinon ou encore le vert vert
à monserau alors les restaurateurs ils
aiment beaucoup les noisettes juste
décoqué ou toréfi ou encore ils
apprécient beaucoup la pâte 100 %
noisette alors vous pouvez retrouver nos
produits en ligne sur notre site
Internet la
noisettedelouest.fr n'oubliez pas on est
à de PES chez
vous